it is part of the sound of the holiday
season you all know it so well the
Salvation Army ringing bells and
collecting donations in those red
kettles there's the sound right there
right now the red Kettle campaign it is
underway but the Salvation Army needs
volunteers Candace Charles is joining us
live this morning to explain kind of
what's behind this shortage but also how
you can help Candace good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
now whether it may be the Fallout from
the pandemic inflation or folks just
forgot this ringing uh this sound really
maybe a little bit quieter in the valley
as folks try to fill up these kettles
but I asked one bell ringer what it
takes to be a volunteer if you guys want
to know find out what I found out take a
look
there's an art to being a Salvation Army
bell ringer Merry Christmas
Christopher corello showed me it's all
about striking the right notes to get
this red Kettle filled ring the bell
play my music and just have a good time
with it the annual red kill campaign is
Salvation Army's Big Money Maker for its
year-round programs but it can't be done
without volunteers it's so satisfying it
makes me feel good the Salvation Army of
Southern Nevada tells me they usually
have about 60 Bell ringers stationed
throughout Southern Nevada this year
they're down 15 to 20 people and each
dollar counts Merry Christmas buddy
during my short stint as a bell ringer I
learned it takes time to collect a book
hopefully everybody is giving this year
and donates the Salvation Army because
the Salvation Army does do a lot for the
whole Community more help would allow
for four instead of eight hour shifts
and more locations this is where 60
locations you will find Bell ringers
this season this week Christopher will
be here spreading a holiday cheer
and raising money for the community one
belly at a time
well folks it seems simple enough right
and fun to do now if you'd like to sign
up to volunteer you can go to
702-870-4430 or if you just want to
donate you can text red Kettle to
51555. of course coming up we're going
to be talking about the drives here's
some of the toys for one of the drives
that you guys can help out with if you
can't donate or if you can't volunteer
and of course we got to cover with all
details on our website 8newsnow.com for
now live from the Salvation Army I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now